what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
all right so getting into secret Empire
part two countess story just gets better
and better I mean this story is
absolutely phenomenal I feel like it's
one of the best stories of cuz that
that's really come out with Captain
America in a long time uh but again you
know this this really takes up with the
aftermath of the destruction of Las
Vegas now keep in mind for the superhero
community they've been holding on by a
thread
right and that's the significance of
secret Empire that's the basis behind
secret Empire the secret Empire I
imagine on some level is supposed to be
political it's supposed to be like a
reflection of the modern day politics I
don't worry about that side of it I just
want to enjoy the story for what it is
and the idea of superheroes basically
being pushed to the point that they feel
like they just literally can't win is
very indicative of oh man Logan of this
just dark atmosphere this dark future
where things are just grim and nobody
can really come back from it anymore
specifically in the realm of New York
keep in mind we saw in the Free Comic
Book Day version and secret Empire
number zero for that New York was just
kind of sucked into the dark world you
know so because of that there's no light
here I mean it's just this this
dimension where there's nothing but
darkness and the darkness is permeated
by these monsters that seek nothing more
than to kill anything they come across
and so all these inhabitants of New York
City have just kind of descended into
absolute madness and this is where
things get absolutely beautiful because
we initially pick up with really just
kind of a handful of those individuals
those heroes that were in New York at
the time it was whisked away so Doctor
Strange Iron Fist Luke Cage so on and so
forth and it's really kind of cool
because it gives these minor heroes a
chance to shine I mean as cool as Luke
Cage is as cool as Iron Fist is at the
end of the day we're still pretty low on
the on the totem pole when it comes to
like the hierarchy of popular heroes in
the realm of Marvel Comics honestly
Netflix you know what do people love you
they're hated it Netflix shined a lot of
light on the character of Iron Fist
where previously people didn't even know
who he was and so again it was really
kind of an interesting concept but it
really also shines a lot of light no pun
intended on the character of dagger
because remember dagger has the ability
to create these sort of psychic
hardlight constructs so to speak but
she's basically the only source of light
in this dimension of Darkness the reason
why is because of the fact content for
the character of Doctor Strange his
efforts are almost always on trying to
get them out of there and so he really
can't exhaust all of his energies
instead dagger serves as the perfect
vegan as a perfect source of light for
any
who's trying to make their way
throughout this city but the issue with
this is that where initially she was
able to extend this power for hours and
hours and hours and for days on end is
taking this you know psychological toll
her bodies perfectly fun but the idea of
standing at the top of the Empire State
Building and just emitting herself as a
beacon of light for hours on end it's
psychologically taxing and that's one of
the great things about secret empires
because it's more than just superheroes
fighting supervillains good guys versus
bad guys it's the psychological effect
that this has on heroes being put in
such weird and strange situations not
only that it actually allows the
villains to shine in a way that they
normally never would and the reason why
this happens is because of the fact that
we actually pick up with a church and
there's a handful of criminals that kind
of break into this church just because
of the fact that this church has been
getting resources in the form of
Medicine different things along those
lines and where some of these hoodlums
break in with the intention of robbing
this priest a guy suddenly shows up
kills one of the criminals and begins
going on this amazing monologue he
basically says you know why are you here
any ideas well you know is you know
we're getting what we want we were going
to give you you know your your cut of
the profits all that kind of good stuff
but it's basically revealed to be the
kingpin and the idea here is that the
kingpin really plays this incredible
role it's almost indicative of the
kingpin from the Netflix daredevil
series which I love Vincent d'Onofrio's
kingpin he was I think he's really one
of the best villains that Marvel's ever
had in the history of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I think he's probably
two standout villains but the idea here
is it he plays very much the role that
were used to if you're not familiar with
kingpin for you he's probably just a
faux Spider Man a faux of daredevil and
that's really about it
but when writers actually take two tasks
and write him as a great villain he is
something to behold he is just
beautifully done in this particular
story and the reason why is because of
the fact that he he basically kills
these criminals and he tells the priest
your your church is under my protection
now I will make sure that you want for
nothing if you need medicine I will give
you the medicine you need if you need
food I will give you the fruit that you
need if you need water if you need any
kind of resources I will be there to
give it to you but when everything comes
back to normal we get back to the better
of a normal state of things keep in mind
who it was that kept you alive now this
is how Wilson Fisk works in a lot of
different ways Wilson Fisk
in a lot of instances we'll just like
strong on his way into stuff right like
he'll just show up and just be like em
this is mine now but in some instances
he'll just kind of work his way in and
he'll intertwine himself into these
particular scenarios and then basically
start calling in favors later on down
the line but what this also does is it
creates a measure of loyalty it's really
some people for the you know in this
instance you will look at keep in and
say what he's not nearly as bad as I
thought he was if you helped to keep us
alive he made sure that we had the
resources that we need
he kept bandits and criminals away from
us we don't really owe him so much as we
respect him in the way that we're going
to make sure that we uphold our end of
the bargain that we treat him with this
measure of respect and so it really
turns into something akin to affection
moreso than like loyalty or the belief
that he somehow owed something so
because of this we kind of transition
out of this dark realm and we actually
pick up with what Tony Stark himself now
again one of the cool things about
secret Empire is it very much picks up
on the state of the Marvel Universe at
this point in time and coming out of
civil war - regardless of you know
whether you love him or hate him Tony
Stark was just one half of the argument
with Carol Danvers on the character of
your listings again I had that Civil War
- video down in the description we're
not going to go too far into a Civil War
- is not a very good story but the idea
here is that Tony Stark made his own
enemies among the superhero community
but the events of secret Empire do not
distinguish which side anybody was on
it's not like Captain America said okay
I'm taking sides and we're going to
start splitting people up so the people
who are going to be you know siding with
Tony Stark or who are going to be stuck
here with Tony Stark are going to be the
same ones who supported him during the
events of Civil War - it's not like that
when the events of secret Empire popped
off and Captain America made his move
and he started just checkmate after
check mate after checkmate and shutting
down all these different superhero
groups just eradicating them or
imprisoning them or whatever the case
may be it ultimately meant that he was
just superheroes scattering for the wind
and hiding as best they could and so
what it meant is that at that point
following the events of Civil War - Tony
Stark in a lot of ways was surrounded by
enemies this is also compounded by the
fact of just Tony Stark's history
superior Iron Man where he was just an
absolute dick to everybody his history
of alcoholism his actions during the
first Civil War
Tony Stark is consistently made enemies
among the superhero community a lot of
different instances and so because of
that a lot of those enemies really
haven't let those issues go they haven't
really walked away it's
yeah you know I mean bygones be bygones
it doesn't really work that way for a
lot of people they still absolutely hate
him and so what he does is he basically
have it calls this truce and this is
okay look guys I know a lot of you guys
don't believe me I know you guys a lot
of you guys don't really think that I'm
a guy who's trustworthy that's fine
let's let Rick Jones speak and of course
brick Jones recorded this message you
know before he had died but the cool
thing about this is that Rick Jones is
positioned as this one guy that
everybody trusts because he was the last
guy to shout Avengers Assemble he was
the one guy who wouldn't give ground who
wouldn't give up who wouldn't walk away
from the idea of what it meant to be a
superhero and so the result of this is
that what Rick Jones basically does is
get us caught up on everything that had
happened so far that you know shield was
messing around with recreating a cosmic
cube the cosmic you was just a fragment
or I guess a combination of different
fragments from other cosmic cubes the
result was that one of these fragments
belong to a cosmic cube that the red
skull had previously attained when the
Cosmic Cube was reformed and the whole
Pleasant Hill event kicked off all that
kind of good stuff and the Avengers and
the media became aware of the fact that
shield was basically tricking the minds
of different villains into believing
that they were in a paradise when they
really weren't when the assault on
Pleasant Hill event took place and
khadak had basically gone through and
began the process of D aging Steve
Rogers in changing his entire backstory
at the whims of the Red Skull then
ultimately it said all these events in
motion that allowed Captain America to
operate behind the scenes without
anybody ever knowing he was a Hydra
agent in the first place now the kicker
to this is that we're comic had
eventually gone on to join the
Thunderbolts under Bucky Barnes this led
to a direct conflict between Captain
America and Bucky Barnes Captain America
killed Bucky Barnes he also killed the
Red Skull and then in turn Erik Selvig
the guy who was basically the science
head next to Captain America working
alongside of him basically dispersed the
shards of the Cosmic Cube all across the
world just because of the fact the idea
was that Captain America was going to
take this cosmic cube and make Hydra a
reality that is to say alter you know
the very fabric of reality itself so
that Hydra was in charge of everything
he was basically going to speedboost his
way all the way up to the top and so the
result is that with these shards kind of
scattered all throughout the world now
it's the hunt for the shards of the
Cosmic Cube it's almost akin to Dragon
Ball Z and the Dragon Ball Z everybody's
hunting for these to be shards of the
Cosmic Cube the result is that where
Tony Stark and his forces in the midst
of mustering themselves together in
order to race off and achieve this goal
Captain America's doing the exact same
thing remember
Rodgers is none too happy about the idea
that he had to display this extreme show
of force by wiping out Las Vegas but it
was necessary for him to do that or at
least for him to order it done for the
very purpose of showing the fact that
he's willing to do whatever it takes in
order to make sure that Hydra stays in
control now the other half of this is
remember Baron Zemo is like his man in
the corner I mean it's his right-hand
man Baron Zemo will basically carry out
virtually any task the Captain America
asks him to
and that's why Captain America goes to
Baron Zemo and says I want you to track
down the charge of the Cosmic Cube I
want you to leave no stone unturned none
do whatever you have to kill whoever you
have to but do what needs to be done and
get me this shard of the Cosmic Cube now
the other half of this is that we
actually pick up about 24 hours after
all this in Colorado and the reason why
is because of the fact that Natasha
Romanoff could basically raced off for
the intention of both young grabbing
these shards and at the same time trying
to track down and kill Captain America
the issue with this is that she's
eventually located by the champions
themselves and this is really cool
because the champions basically go to
her and say look you have a level of
training that we couldn't even begin to
comprehend and that's true with Natasha
Romanoff she's got no powers but she
does have prodigiously when it comes to
espionage I mean she's really the
world's greatest assassin and so because
of that the champions going to her is
basically saying look we need you to
train us in a way that we've never been
trained before we've been trained to
defend we've been trained to stop
threats what we need is training on how
to kill threats and this again is
designed to show us there's just this
tipping point this point at which
everything just kind of switches that
it's not necessarily the superhero
landscape that we're used to anymore the
things have gotten darker things have
gotten grittier more so than that things
have gotten desperate for the superhero
community and so because of this what
ends up happening here is we basically
have Natasha Romanoff simply saying
welcome to the Red Room that's what
we're going to do we're basically going
to switch over to this idea that I'm
going to train you in the exact same way
that I was trained so it's really kind
of a cool concept but in the midst of
all this what we do is we actually
switch to this weird location this weird
place which we now know as the vanishing
point but the idea here is that there's
just some chick just kind of running for
her life
you guys will notice the art style is
distinctly different this girl is
running for her life right just kind of
fleeing these weird things it looks like
members of the serpent Society or what
have you once they actually descend on
her and they intend to kill her these
guys are all defeated by some unnamed
person
but when this person is addressed by
this woman when she asked who are you
and what do you want this man simply
answers by saying my name is Steve
Rogers and I'm just trying to get home
but that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comment explain make
sure you guys said the sublet did become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all on earth please
[Music]